many people who try to enter the US
legally are in fact turned away because
of a huge backlog in asylum applications
a UN report just out this morning says
for the first time since 2012 the u.s.
leads the world in request for asylum
more than 640,000 people had pending
applications at the end of last year and
that's 44 percent more than 2016 but the
u.s. had only made decisions on about 10
percent of those requests David Beck
knows at a port of entry in Hildago
Texas that's just south of where we are
in McAllen David good morning hey Gail
good morning so this is one of eleven
land ports along the us-mexico border
this is where the Trump administration
and other administrations have told
people you can come without being
detained or potentially separated from
your children now listen there are major
delays back up so many people are trying
to get in legally that there's a delay
in processing those applications get a
look at some of these numbers that we've
assembled for you there are currently
about 700,000 pending immigration cases
in this country that is an increase of
14 percent over last fiscal year and a
238 percent increase since 2009 now even
if you can submit your application the
average wait time to get in front of an
immigration judge is nearly two years
now look we've heard stories of people
who've come here waited days or weeks
and only get turned away after
immigration just after the Border Patrol
tells them look we're at capacity
sometimes they're told to come back at a
later date that's some of the reasons
Gail that people give as to why they
cross the border and when you do that
you're committing a federal crime
Gail over the last couple of days in
speaking with Border Patrol they've told
us that they feel like they're being
attacked unfairly I spoke with one agent
who's a mother she's high-ranking and
she said David I hate the idea of
separating families but she said what
bothers me even more is knowing that
moms and dads put their kids in that
position that when they cross the border
they know that I'm gonna take them and
their child in the custody
all right David but people really want
to be here because of the way they're
treated at home thank you very much